once we can create immersive digital
environments that are fully immersive
that are just as real as our everyday
matrix that we have to share with others
those digital environments can be just
for us so we can each become God in our
own custom-made digital universe hi I'm
Zach why smaller for recent TV we're
here in New York City at the Tribeca
Film Festival I'm with Jason Silva he's
a filmmaker host of NAT Gio's brain
games and a self-described techno
optimist are you still a techno optimist
there's been a lot of techno pessimism
in the wake of you know all the Snowden
revelations were government harnessing
technology to spy on all of us can you
make us feel better about it all yes
look people have always been afraid of
disruptive technologies technologies the
signal transformation that signal change
that signal the world operating under a
different set of parameters you know but
when we invented the alphabet writing
Socrates Plato all the intellects of the
day used to say that if you wrote things
down it was gonna answer for your brain
because your we're gonna have to
remember anything so we've always been
terrified smartphones people are like oh
we're looking up everything on Google so
we don't retain any information that's
not true it's just these are technology
I always say this technology is our it's
our exoskeleton you know iPhone
therefore I am
but as Kevin Kelly says as long as our
sphere of possibilities is enhanced then
there's a net gain it's not utopia but
it's kind of leaning that way the world
has never been less violent you know a
young person in Africa where the
cellphone has better communications
technology than the US president had 25
years ago so you know I think we're
doing better but yeah it's a
double-edged sword you can use the
technology of fire to burn people or you
can used to cook your food we talked
about this three years ago so but do you
worry about the the way that it has been
used by the states of surveil people I
think that what people have to realize
is that I don't envision a bunch of
agents sitting around spying on you and
caring like what you're googling about
huh you know I think it's software
algorithms they're looking for patterns
in the data because there's billions of
people that are serving the inner in at
any given time that's more than any
cognitive brains could ever keep track
of
if they're like spying on your personal
web surfing habits no there are
algorithms that are looking for patterns
that are looking for people who are
trying to do bad things like blow [ __ ]
up you know and you know if you're
emailing people about blowing [ __ ] up
then it should show up on a pattern
recognition engine that the NSA is using
and you should be questioned you know
like we need to have some kind of
compromise to live inside of a sort of
consensus society where we agree that
you're not supposed to hurt other people
and so on and so forth that I'm all
about free speech but you know again
there are key words there are key terms
there are key things that if people are
actively talking about it raises some
flags and I can understand where that
coming from so I'm not an alarmist about
it you know cuz again I'm not up to bad
things so well you know David Brin read
a book called the transparent society
and he talks about this concept of
sousveillance where yes the government's
looking down on us but it's a you know
two way road where we can look at them
on you you envision that kind of you
know totally transparent society moving
forward or how do you think that's gonna
play out well the whole idea of of
privacy is a cultural invention right I
mean there was a time when you know the
tribe and the village and everybody knew
everything about everyone you know
they're the whole privacy thing emerged
kind of out of the new you know
Industrial Revolution socio economic
models buy a house have a private room
privately with it these are things that
we got to take for granted but they're
not necessarily set in stone but um yes
I guess yeah they can watch us and we
can watch them and together that creates
a decentralized system and again Steven
Johnson talks about this in a future
perfect decentralized networks that you
know can look that can regulate each
other you know you don't have top-down
you just have you know what is it it's
how airplanes work the pilot watches the
autopilot watching the pilot do you know
what I mean so it's like that the people
watch the government watch the people
watch the government so you post show on
that Geo called brain games great shots
in its third season so congratulations
what can we learn about the brain based
on you know kind of having fun these
these games what do they teach us about
the brain
well I think you know with brain games
we tell people that one of the main
ideas is that you know perception is
tightly coupled to reality and as Joseph
Campbell used to say reality is a word
you can't use without quotation marks
around it we don't see the world as it
is we see the world as we are and I
think through the games these are like
entertaining funny fun ways that we do
on brain games we create these
experiments that allow people to in a
non terrifying way be reminded of how
little they perceive of their everyday
reality and so it is through the prism
of our brain making edits and
guesstimating and filling in the blanks
that we create the matrix of
first-person subjective experience which
is highly limited and i think i'm
bringing games we make people aware of
that so you talked earlier about you
know living in a kind of consensus world
how do we come to that consensus if
we're all looking through the subjective
prism yeah well I think that's why
people like Terence Mckenna talked about
our cultural operating systems these
reality tunnels Robert Anton Wilson says
we had to agree on a congruent set of
symbols on an approximation of a
consensus sort of trance because it's
all a construct it's all grids it's all
made up it's all a manufactured dream
space you know like we draw that line
and we say cars go on that side and the
other car goes on that side the right
way to go is on the right side it's an
artificial construct but we need to come
up with a consensus Tran so we don't
crash into each other we need to come up
with a consensus right so we don't kill
each other any kind of cooperation
requires creating this grid this shared
dream space you know love love is a
cosmology shaped like a heart love is a
shared dream space technology sports
another shared dream space technology
and artificial reality that we know we
can all agree on so we can get something
done you know so anytime the human
beings collaborate they have to create a
consensus trance but it doesn't mean
that it's set in stone it's not fixed
because these are malleable reality I
mean do you feel like technology allows
more malleability and more
individualization of these dream spaces
of course you know the whole the whole
point is with virtual reality with
technologies like oculus rift offer
offering a glimpse of what's coming you
know Terence Mckenna was saying this 20
years ago you know when he was high on
psychedelic mushrooms what he was saying
virtual reality is increasingly leading
us towards
versus of our own construction because
once we can create immersive digital
environments that are fully immersive
but are just as real as our everyday
matrix that we have to share with others
those digital environments can be just
for us so we can each become God in our
own custom-made digital universe we
don't have to have a consensus trance
anymore it can be literally our dream
just for us we are the star of our own
movie so that's I think what people are
excited about Jason Silva host of
natchios brain games you can also see
his videos online shots of awe it's
called on YouTube thanks very much for
talking to us for recent TV I'm Zack
Weissmuller